Russian President Vladimir Putin says
Moscow will help North Korea build
satellites if Pyongyang asks he made the
comments while meeting the North Korean
leader Kim Jong-un in Russia's Far East
they're at the mastodoni cosmodrome
Putin also said he and Kim would discuss
a wide range of issues the U.S suspects
Kim Jong-un is ready to supply weapons
to Moscow for the war in Ukraine
in a moment we'll speak to Euless in
Moscow but first let's bring in Florence
Louis who's in Seoul Florence her face
to face meeting and a long handshake a
significant meeting then for a number of
reasons
absolutely this is the second meeting
between these two leaders but it is Kim
jong-un's first trip abroad since the
covet pandemic now these two leaders
haven't been particularly close but
there appears to be an intention to
project closeness now Kim Jong-un has
been reported as saying by a North
Korean State media that his visit to
Russia really highlights
um North Korea's priority in putting
ahead in in building stronger ties with
Russia now North Korean State media has
given this visit full coverage and I
think we can take from that that there
is a lot of importance placed on these
ties between Russia and North Korea and
also perhaps a level of confidence that
talks indeed between these two leaders
are going to go well now both each side
has what the other ones Russia wants
weapons and North Korea wants hard
currency it wants food it wants
technology to help it Advance its
nuclear weapons program now both sides
are also ruled by authoritarian leader
this and they are both finding
themselves increasingly isolated Russia
because of its war on Ukraine and North
Korea because of its nuclear weapons
program which has been which is in
contravention of U.N Securities Council
resolutions and sanctions assumptions so
ahead of this so you know even before
this meeting there has been a clear
intention to project an image of
closeness Russia really rolled out the
red carpet for Kim Jong-un having a
minister meet him when he arrived at the
Border Town on Tuesday morning and now
all these remarks that we're hearing
from these two leaders you know Kim
saying um thank you thanking Putin for
taking time out of his busy schedule to
meet him Putin saying I'm very glad to
meet you so really an intention to
project closeness and perhaps after this
meeting we might find that these two
countries have agreed on even closer
cooperation militarily and perhaps
economically as well and given what you
say then what is the international
reaction been to the Kim Putin meeting
well the U.S has warned about a possible
arms deal taking place and so we've
heard U.S officials renew their warnings
and also threatening to impose new
sanctions if such a deal were to go
ahead and regionally while countries
like South Korea and also Japan have
said they're watching developments very
closely they've also urged these two
countries to not do anything to violate
U.N sanctions because they're both U.N
members now we've also heard South
Korean precedent urge China as a
permanent member of the U.N security
Council to do more to reign in North
Korea
South Korea also saying that it will
deepen its ties with Japan and with the
US to curb the rising threat from
Pyongyang but many analysts believe that
China would be the key here in
preventing an arms deal between Russia
and North Korea from going ahead now
China so far has not issued many
comments apart from having its foreign
Ministry spokesperson say that
um
well what we're seeing well apart from
having its foreign Ministries spokesmen
say that this visit is a matter between
these two countries but some analysts in
China are saying that what we're seeing
here is just a reaction to what the U.S
has been doing in the region for years
in um deepening its military cooperation
the intensifying military exercises with
Partners in the region and also in
conducting more freedom of navigation
operations and make no mistake that
North Korea and um
China and Russia have both criticized
U.S dominance in this region Florence
Louis thank you for that I'm going to
stay with this Euler shapavalova joins
us live now from Moscow what's the
schedule for the two leaders now that
they've met face to face and initial
comments have been made
absolutely Kim jong-un's a meeting with
Vladimir Putin has already begun there
at the vostochny cosmodrome in Russia as
far east and obviously we've heard from
Vladimir Putin as saying that Russia is
ready to help North Korea with its
satellite program uh its own satellite
program its glorious satellite program
goes back to Soviet times to last
century right now the interfax agency
raised that Putin and Kim will inspect
several facilities there at the cosmo
drove and then will hold negotiations it
is expected that the North Korean leader
will be shown how the angara launch
vehicle has been assembled there and
then the leaders will also inspect the
launch complex of the angara as well as
the launch complex for the soyuz 2
launch vehicle which is still under
construction there and after that they
will hold negotiations uh well Russia
never actually revealed the topic of
their talks but we've heard earlier from
the United States dates and from some
unless they believe that Putin and Kim
intended to discuss first of all the
supply of ammunition from North Korea
for the Russian army fighting in Ukraine
and in response came allegedly wants to
receive Food Aid and some military and
space Technologies as well as some
technologies for nuclear submarines from
Russia well just a day before speaking
at the Eastern economic Forum uh
President Putin confirmed that he was
intended to he intended rather to visit
the cosmodrome but did not tell the
details of his program there saying when
I get there you will find out
um by the way the vastroshni cosmodrome
is a brand new Spaceport of Russia the
construction of some of its parts it
still underway as I said and Russia is
trying to accumulate the latest its
latest and most advanced space and
satellite technology there it translates
as the eastern cosmodrome and it was
intended to reduce Russia's depend on
other countries for its Pace exploration
program since the mid-20th century
Russia's space agency had depended on
the baikanu cosmodrome in Kazakhstan as
its primary launch site I knew that
overall then what's the Russian
perspective of Kim's visit how is it
being seen where you are
what we're just getting reports of that
meeting uh basically we I can't say that
the expectations are high because
basically all the points have been
discussed before uh obviously uh the
whole world as well as Russia are
closely watching the results of this uh
meeting and uh because we understand
that it can affect the balance of power
in the region and in the entire on the
entire planet recently Russia supported
North Korea verbally verbally but now it
wasn't a well now it's it well we hear
some talks that Russia can withdraw from
the Yuan sanctions imposed on North
Korea before because uh right now Russia
is trading more and more with North
Korea compared to previous times because
Russia was adhering to those U.N
sanctions uh so all that is happening
because of Russia's isolation in the
west because the relations are becoming
close with North Korea now Russia of
course needs artillery shells from North
Korea while North Korea being one of the
most militarized countries in the world
can provide those ammunitions to Russia
for us in Moscow thank you
well let's bring in Robert Kelly now
he's professor of political science at
Busan at National University joins us
from Busan welcome to the program so in
Practical terms and all the handshakes
and smiles are done what will both sides
actually be hoping to get out of this
okay so for the Russians I think the big
thing is getting the ammunition the
shells and the bullets as your
correspondent was just talking about I
think it's pretty clear at this point
that the Russian defense industrial base
cannot keep up with the needs of the
Russian army out in the field in Ukraine
that war has gone on much longer than
the Russians had anticipated we know
they're using tanks from like the 1960s
that tells us that the Russians are
having real sort of shortages internally
and going to the North Koreans is sort
of I guess you know a stop Gap if you
will right until the Russians can sort
of catch up themselves I think the big
issue on the Russian side then is sort
of the failure rate the quality of this
Russian this North Korean ammunition
right will these these shells actually
work on the on the North Korean side I
think the upside is very large which is
that the Russians are desperate and the
North Koreans can give this ammunition
and in exchange they can get stuff they
really can't develop the Technologies
has been mentioned for nuclear subpower
or for satellites so and I think though
the benefits really fall best for the uh
North Koreans well indeed I mean how big
a boost is this for not just materially
but for his image on the world stage we
see him shaking hands with President
Putin there
yeah that's right that's another good
point too right this is the same reason
why Kim Jong-un went to meet Donald
Trump back in 2018 and 19 even though
that didn't really turn into anything
meaningful right North Korea is pretty
isolated but it is in a direct kind of
existential legitimacy contest with
South Korea which is to say the North
Koreans want to prove that they are in
fact a real Korean State and not some
weird failed offshoot where South Korea
is the real Korea um and so one of the
ways the North Koreans do that is they
want International recognition so they
ran off to meet Trump to get the
pictures you do the same thing with
Vladimir Putin you know Russia's sort of
a great power right it's got a permanent
seat on the security Council so this
sort of raises North Korea's profile
which is as you might imagine pretty low
compared to to South Korea right that's
one of the reasons why Kim was willing
to leave the country which is pretty
extraordinary
and what will China make of this then
given that it has bilateral relations
with both Russia and North Korea
yeah that's a really good question
that's sort of a wild card right and we
know that the Chinese have allowed the
North Koreans to park illicit money in
Chinese banks for a while the Chinese
have looked the other way on sanctions
busting but the Chinese have also been
sort of nervous that the North Koreans
might overreach right the Chinese oppose
Korean unification they don't want a
unified Korea on their border but they
also don't want an unhinged nuclear
North Korea that sort of provokes the
planet you know provokes the United
States and sort of could stumble into a
conflict right China would like North
Korea to sort of just it to exist but be
calm and the North Koreans are not like
that right so I think the Chinese are
kind of in a weird spot here you know
they want the war to in Ukraine to win
uh to end soon they want the Russians to
win right they want to keep the North
Korean nuclear program from spinning out
of control and provoking a real American
response so I actually am not quite sure
what the Chinese think if I had to guess
I'd say they're probably actually
opposed to this because they're worried
that the North Koreans and the Russians
are going to go off and make a deal that
the Chinese wouldn't actually make with
either of those Partners themselves you
touched on the US there what will
America be thinking about this and South
Korea
yeah I think the American response is
pretty obvious it's going to be negative
and the South Korean response Under This
president's Health Care has a
conservative presence sort of a hawk on
North Korea and he is hold he said to
the Russians publicly right that because
Russia has a security council member and
it has voted for the sanctions on North
Korea that you know Russia is not
allowed to do this which is correct by
the way Security Council resolutions are
technically international law and the
Russians aren't supposed to do this I
think you know Putin is I think a Putin
at this point is so desperate in Ukraine
that he just doesn't care right um and
that's just going to alienate him even
more from from South Korean public
opinion right and I think the Americans
are very very nervous that you know the
Russians are going to give the North
Koreans something really valuable like
you know satellite technology right
right the North Koreans would like
better satellites to guide their nuclear
missiles right including missiles that
may be pointed at the United States so I
think the Americans are actually quite
nervous about this Robert Kelly we very
much appreciate your time here in Al
Jazeera thank you